l'élégance ce fut le maître mots d'yves
saint laurent en 40 ans de création et
c'est avec la même élégance que le plus
grand couturier français a annoncé son
départ ce matin quelques mots sincères
et beaucoup d'émotion pour celui qui a
toujours défendu une certaine idée de la
femme sans céder justement aux toutes
dernières modes sabine gorny luc hedrich
l'arrivée discrète du maître des lieux
dans sa chair maison culture là où
depuis 40 ans et fabriqué la légende
mais ce matin les choeurs sont serrés
l'émotion palpable
costume noir prémonitoire monsieur saint
laurent dit au revoir
j'ai choisi aujourd'hui de dire adieu à
ce métier plaisait tant aimée c'est
aussi à ses fantômes d'esthétique mais
je dis à dieu je vais connais depuis mon
enfance c'est pour les retrouver que je
choisis ce merveilleux métier
quelques lignes lue avec pudeur et
dignité pour dire cette vie pleine de la
joie de créer plein d'angoissé d'un
génie tourmenté inquiet tout entier au
service de la beauté
un texte pour dire merci aux fidèles
atelier à la famille à pierre bergé le
pygmalion l'ami de toujours celui avec
qui l'histoire de la maison se devait de
s'achever comme elle avait commencé
il a pris sa décision seul calmement et
je trouve que ça manque de respect
d'abord ça et que jacqueline eu beaucoup
beaucoup la tristesse
beaucoup savent et c'est un petit
chef-d'oeuvre l'arrêté commencé il ya 40
ans se termine sans bavure
j'ai conscience d'avoir fait progresser
la mode de mon temps et d'avoir permis
aux femmes d'accéder à un univers jusque
là luxe calme et volupté
la haute couture ou l'art du sur mesure
pour des clients de fortunés prêts à
payer très cher le prix de l'exclusivité
saint-laurent s'en va une maison
disparaît avec tout le savoir faire des
ateliers jeux face est bouleversée quand
même parce que je ne croyais que je
voulais pas y croire
je ne voulais pas croire tu es un
artiste aussi génial cesse de créer en
fait c'est comme comme un père comme à
j'ai pas dis ah oui c'est vrai je suis
triste aussi pour lui presque plus pour
lui que pour tout le monde ici ça va
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il a ce
sentiment
de n'être plus à sa place dans un monde
qu'il ne pourra pas car la mode
appartient désormais aux financiers en
99 françois pinault racheter la maison
saint laurent et en confier le
prêt-à-porter un texan tom ford
pour yves saint laurent il fallait
accepter que son nom sa griffe soit
désormais aussi la signature d'un autre
ce prince de l'élégance a préféré
s'éclipser âge est chaleureux et d'où on
a l'impression qui referme doucement la
porte voilà monsieur saint-laurent jette
le des seuls couturier avoir ouvert et
fermé sa maison de son plein gré en
toute liberté